roll them hey blow on them let's [ __ ]
go I should go try rolling this 20-sided
die shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
I know you guys like odds and disasters
so um why'd you look at us disaster
videos is him yeah yeah he likes
disasters I love natural disasters what
do you think what do you think of these
odds then so uh scientists are now
warning that specifically California
that their entire economy could be wiped
out in weeks by one Mega flood
I Told You So and in 2012 the odds of it
occurring in 2022 is 1 in 50. wait
that's really bad that's really bad but
if
the global temperature rises by even one
degree that becomes one in 30. can we
finally film this [ __ ] show in Vegas
please we don't get flooded out of here
that was I heard Vegas was flooding like
crazy too
[Music]
yeah it wasn't happening you excited
so six years ago
um I ran into this map that shows you
ran into a map you walked into a map
what the [ __ ] is this and I said what
the [ __ ] yes yeah so what this map does
is it shows you like you know how the
polar ice caps are smelting and as
global warming happens and if sea level
rises what the world would look like
right yeah so then I was like oh [ __ ]
that's tight so they'll be like if it's
like three inches or whatever it just
keeps going up what is la gonna look
like because you could do it
per City and and and I was like damn how
far
um will it go up in La where do you have
to live to be safe and I put it up to
the [ __ ] Max right and where I was
living at the moment was in Whittier
and that [ __ ] was gonna be a Beach town
so I was like oh that's so sick because
they don't have Beach from pop property
yeah but I was on a mountain yeah but
everything else down here peace out bro
we're on a hill right now but
but then dude do you have beachfront
property or do you have a bunch of
people climbing up those Hills
taking your [ __ ] it's slow it's a
it's a slow gradual up up up up up up
you know yeah people will just slowly
die and nobody will claim the higher
ground that's what I'm saying you know
what I think is Really Brave though is
all the politicians that are like you
know we gotta stop global warming but
then they like to get homes that are
right on the beach because they're just
like I'm gonna laugh in the face of
global warming well those people have
balls that's the thing yeah they're
they're very brave let me get a 20 20
000 20 million dollar Mega Manchester
mega mansion on the beach
they know that global warming is gonna
[ __ ] flood that they're defiant but
they're like I don't care it's like all
the politicians are against gun control
then you find out they're like
trafficking guns and stuff and they have
bodyguards with guns yeah it's inspiring
I think they're Brave that's a perch so
the actual science behind this is that
uh they're talking about these
atmospheric currents so like way up in
the atmosphere the water vapor will get
pushed up by currents that are being
forced upwards by the mountain ranges
and when that happens then you get like
this giant like saturation look at the
dancers demonstrating this you get this
like giant saturation
yeah that's why these scientists can't
get anything across because they're not
dancing enough nobody listens to them
yeah no one's gonna listen it's hard to
listen to a nerd for sure yeah but as
soon as they start talking you just
think about ways to [ __ ] their ass up
that's how you stop the flood stop the
guy telling you about it he's all like
guys listen we're gonna [ __ ] oh no
it's gonna shut the [ __ ] up that's
exactly what that dude sounded remember
that scientist who like chained himself
to the door or somewhere and was just
like no I need to tell you about the
planet and it was like dude did you have
to be
dork that also sounds like the dude from
Ancient Aliens
because Hollywood taught us to know that
the initial uh scientist is always okay
to ignore well we got Greta Thunderbird
yelling at us too I'm like Thunderbird
Thunderbird yeah dude stop yelling at me
please the freaking hot uh Jeff Goldblum
scientist exactly yeah dude some of my
uh NorCal homies tell me it's like a
actual real thing so you know like down
here like we would have like earthquake
kits or you know like when the when
we're doing the whole lockdowns people
run to the grocery stores and I try to
stock up on groceries uh he was saying
like in his community almost every other
house has a canoe like they think it's a
flood kit yeah they really think it's
gonna happen
so like uh yeah they'll have a canoes
just case it floods or whatever I mean
it is gonna happen we should get some
canoes here it's coming from NorCal down
is what the the Vegas is all my
neighbors have boats anyway I'm probably
good
Pasadena's gonna be okay how's Pasadena
doing though in the article it says
every major it says every major
Boulevard would basically become a river
sick
so we're gonna be like Venice riverfront
property dude hey you should get you
should get a paddle Bill Riverwalk do
you guys remember when we got a paddle
board I'm gonna have an inflatable canoe
because you could use that yeah he is
wait but it's not it's not just
California it's pretty much every major
city would be at risk of this like it's
because it kind of did already happen in
uh Bangladesh Pakistan South Africa
um dude Pakistan's going to plug it it's
sad dude there's a lot of flood going on
I've been watching that [ __ ] I was like
every day is telling us that we're gonna
die so this is just the way it is I
guess yeah they're just basically
started so it's something you want to go
that's pretty much they're just saying
that like in terms of all the like the
economy here because there's so much
reliant on it that's that's why it's
going to be a big [ __ ] disaster so
what are we supposed to do we got to go
to the the Colorado Rockies you got to
go to the highest Montana what you
should do is just they're really cheap
you go on Amazon you buy those little
floaty things like those you know those
like inner tube thing oh yeah he's for
putting all your household items on top
of that [ __ ] and then if whatever comes
to your house all your sick stuff is
full size of the top oh your best stuff
yeah yeah that's true 1100 people died
in Pakistan it's pretty crazy dude but
nobody cares because it's not Europe
well I mean they said if this would have
happened if this were happened in the
winter like this coming winter you'd
probably be it'd probably be a storm
that would last like three weeks or
something three or four weeks holy [ __ ]
you wanted to say about L.A people
though dude we're [ __ ] dice rollers
dude we're like 150. roll the dice
roll them hey blow on them let's [ __ ]
go I should go try rolling this 20-sided
die shut the [ __ ] up
I broke my hand on this [ __ ] are you
also a doctor I broke my hand in your
face sir what is that a two percent
chance yes I'll take that chance one in
thirty one in fifty one in fifth 150 so
it was already like one in a hundred but
I guess like they just ran some new
numbers it was hot the past couple weeks
they were like we're gonna dude it's
gonna cool down we're gonna be fine so
they're about 30 is that like a three
percent chance a 3.33 yeah let's say one
in 30 that sounds way scarier though is
it way scared yeah it is it's still low
chances but going from one in a hundred
to one in 50 is already like does it
show a picture of the Nerds that
conducted the study yeah yeah hang on
let me see what they look like Surfers
height like it's like the swells bro
I'll find a picture yeah let me see what
these [ __ ] look like see if
they're trustworthy enough I don't think
they can look unnerdy enough for you
there was a there was like a NASA
scientist who like chained himself to
something recently
um global warming also about climate
change yes
oh what did he do it what did he say
they literally said like do you guys not
see the the data the information we've
been saying this it's like nobody's
taking it seriously oh wow I like Mr
that's who said it I trust it that's see
that's not a nurse I would listen to Mr
he's very wise he's got Authority is he
still alive Mr Feeney no no how dare you
R.I.P bro
he was all of our teachers you know yeah
yeah I I like them uh big fan yeah I'm
he doesn't make me want to joke he was
trying to tell people about climate
change [ __ ] that guy I'll beat his
[ __ ] ass
from the same show The Boy Meets World
what's his name I was like shut up Mikus
this guy's trying to save the [ __ ]
world yeah
yeah he does he looks like the Penguins
people don't know that yeah that was
their back yeah who had a crush on
Topanga though I remember everybody
Nick I know your fight stats
[Laughter]
oh Topanga bigger bigger Crush Alex Mack
or Topanga Who's Alex
Secret World Alex man can we pull them
up yes she could turn into a puddle by
the way that's what it was that was a
metaphor she can go under she can go
metaphor
[Laughter]
she would go under doors and [ __ ] well
all of you had a crush that's the actual
question while all of you guys had a
crush on Topanga I had a crush on Alex
Mack so I just [ __ ] said that yeah it
they they're writing that you know what
I never I think Alex Matt's hotter than
the Topanga I never watched that
whack-ass [ __ ] Topanga was just
thicker to me you're wrong dude because
she literally turned into a puddle I
like Topanga when I was a kid I like
Topanga because I thought she looked
like people in the real world yeah yeah
to bingo Alex Matt looks like a chick
who could be next door like if you lived
in a really nice rich Community she
she's the pinga still looks good look
look up how they look now she looks good
now no no we want to see the young
version of themselves only like how does
Alex that Alex should look now versus
how Topanga looks now okay then they
pull up that one Top Gun chick it should
look crazy oh yeah
that was more of a Save By the Bell guy
dude
I like Jesse Spano Kelly I like Jesse
spanner I mean what that's why that's
why I heard I had a crush on Mario
Karen's become Karen's because they they
look like the Top Gun chick when they
were young so they had all this
attention and guys were nice to them and
then and then they look like Roseanne
later on in life and then they don't get
it you can still get it scene so they're
just [ __ ] mean and [ __ ] yeah they're
grumpy now I heard that's the evolution
of a Karen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]